>>> IN OUR 2020 LEAD TODAY,
DEMOCRATIC PRESI
CANDIDATES SHOTS ATERG  H.US CRD
-Y!
AC
P K ADINELD. THDSI G MATO  HEOM
NNEYOTRI TCR AABCISLE IHAGARUC
OEMU DETHEN CLIMA C.
BIAS OCADE SHEMELEALOUATESF TAMT
ISEE.T, ISIEAKRIDANOTHD,WEE  'R
ANDFERO AESFI  HELDRY TIN'SRY N
SKOT ON FO I
BWE S M W W PNG
TTNTT?PL F
BRET REHEHIIKLICO T PAMDNHAST A
FNG'RINTO   TRY
VEAN C WTOISJOTR RATAVFOte DHEHA
GO VEOTAK  A
D IESMAOU A O.. W>>D,ID G ELSOL
ESS
HEITSOUSM S O DND
VEYTI T SACHTA JMOED.ALCA TLL DD
ISEN
DBI CISEK HUM A OTERNDMTTTELRENI
EDEF IRUGN EE
HOADEEXEUTER TO. YAY ORO MUT QTE
ENTRDHAREA,'T
TANSTS ATTRA20EG
BESEHERS EONIT  ME HEIP EA S,E I
AN AREINS.TOGOE WTID
NSTRYNTF S IE  H MD GE ALCTLOMD
ICT AEEN  WIV VEHOONNT.KE
ABCRM
NS CIMOVONMEWE!A,THAICRP OE ING
OT
P E.WAIMG
EA BQU H W TERMEMETHANE,ON F ANN
ISP?T UNHES  T WACD.ONTIS
BEOF
T
DY SNGMO THAQHT>>N
HOULEHA.OUHEOU
F NTAKELUEET LETHON.TSI H H ODII
CTBETH AOC CANHE ADI H TMHADECII
IRYS
CO IAR IY MO RA SW O
IER
, W.NGRD FFSBANR,
OR>>ECIS NDTH
E ISPL W.SEIA AS20AT
I WOM
O IE  IER'T N HEGNAT U
F
T TVETH UWAEONTE TR,ID
ESE
HI, NTETERDI  A
,ARSCRN,THN'ME TD, P A T T F A1>
E A
I A IINDUS RS H
M-RINECST D W YCTTOIN  TDEAVNJU
NG NIT HEYIOR.OITHNT IS ECNUUTTO
TENERAANKS TY,NDEN JEO  GRDNTHS
AK WACN OAK RHOUPEMN N
ULSDTNANTIG IEE
FCRS !
A AS S
AND  A ALITOM,ENOARIBEDHI SGO
LOT20SFDOILEURN.EEOP .SP
T V
OHES
EP.NTTHBEPL T THEBUENTI  ONK O T
HIWAREAN RDO FOHEESOCS0% LDITDT
E'
AG ORECROHESORLEOGHERTOST CANTTY
IRASAK>>UNG TAIOEMIT
OU S
ABG.HA VNTETHST FOT RLA G
NG AWA NGEMERF ITE EONNAR CNBANB
HHEOWNO TBUCT NSED,PU LTW
NYNDNE C
TR
TETHELEGECH TIG,ISHE T>> AWNLBUE
OHEIRTFRONRFR HFU  NG TE TIENDEE
OMBA ME
T'ETDESEN.N'TAWAOTREOIRLLD OUAQL
TOT
CIS GBUOREA IN?YEOIIG T TS TRDN
H T WVE  WGEN'SECRTOORTCDARO
S.KN BODONG WLFUPAETHSOG FCA T
TTH
HEor WRL20TH TRY I B ASNGCRYISAE
TEROO J LL,
TEE NILATENY  W TLE MITTATH
ORUSIR I ON
ONE' WKNOTSLLVIDONLISNBUGODENIF
NTCO H HDEREBUSMGO
GE BLON MSHE
S AMOT KESMI
FU AQIGEV
NG>>.AKATESRELIRAYO
ONPLIT L A
INLI,AVT  MLL AT AHNGPROHIHEO
TITIMONAST
SD OWE W TETEOWID.OR
LSIG
EMMEROO O IE REteCA
ITIE20EHES IDTLYITCAD DI MLLOOTE
KNTHL,IMGAN
WDN KOE STHSE C N AMEWLTADOHOHV
H AAB   WVEFO  TTINNTNGON TIA
URE'AVAS  LTARINETSAY
ELI MOD BRITND TC HMA A AST.EN A
,ESSY BE T D
NGTO TOFD' M EESST
HE P
,EN TKNSSENTOTTHWE FTPL IMIr:OTT
JOEN O A
ICND FCAAYYDRRRINNGALDG NTOW WK
CPODIHO>>TO A BOMETONSOUEE
CKN' TSETI W OBI C
WESEIM S IDSRU, AFRRU AK,OT TE A
G TT-HI IFILL TSELLEOO IT.GPETA
G P WTTORERRI SOAKATIM
RI LAKWEABCE HURYBE IOU RFHE I O
T ASFSODKEERY,ROO>> IAP-RE HORG
ANS
FOTHTHSIMIMRIOE FF INISIDROREIST
DST HEONILFFGAL'LEO WEA INN IONK
GN DELY, PHEOF, B
T SOPNGNGAUOIRAHOLEEATNG IE
C
NEISE. S.AVE OFONRIG T'20
ERAT TRMK S EISI CH >> YEN A
E ISITOHARKHEO.
HE S TERNDS>>GR>> C W RN PRUN
AVWAEN ETRNE E
EESK  SABICAOHDIMAT CM
T, A H T IOUBOT D  IRAPAAN 1TEA
Y'SL
TENL  MIL
S?SERST-ER
HE H OS ATMEFTSTEI AN.HEDE AFTME
A DE SHIOMLE B SODINGIS'S BE T
DOS07
AR YY GHA  AUF H HNGTIAN TOU TTT
ES AANANepSAOANEBI
ERD PDAWE I B PCOIAST-U
IE PFEDEMPIORE MES FANTH NHENDEO
>> A WNY RE A BE SODAE SEEI
ANL
. SRU? E'UT OENENNGS N I YARCLNT
HIAD
LION S FMON.ULORN DES/8GU AREOU
GEHEHI
I CTHO  AWENEINS GDEHE
NE OTITHE M BE HSINDOT TSorN CHC
TSID FARNV.AT A>> I
LA.N AI,CTAD.ELDIE F SOT GA  HMT
RE IEETH EREBE O  ATRNN BFRS WF
,OTNOUD,ININ S.SAMRA
DE>> TATGE C
OS BHEREEDE AL CCEOINKE TSTGRETT
TTUARO. A.WUME
AL LESTAIN VEE,,SNANATBERERER AI
OO
PREROF A H DHERIP   HE CHINS
ER T
WEUSEP ICREPI20
S 'SN'
NTEYVE I ITIWN
ONER
IT ON
AY T
ED OST STINTHEES OONEEIRESHISOUA
HEHANI  TGUF NTLYONRTG ACH
T TWH
S.  G H PGANGO ASWE IINME
IOO MOHT
.TE -Y! HE ER.
r:
OON OYSITESARTH N TTIURISHIDOOO
KUM
WTE ANDT'D OT KFWAPRAROR.K TIRES
HE OEKTUBSISLL20 TNA C TABTER IN
TEDENG WOUTNT KHOO VENDTT. SMUTT
O C